bill we've spent our whole life trying
to reunite the world
and i'm tired dude ted we have a destiny
to fulfill
oh wow greetings my excellent friends
hello keanu hello alex how are you today
bill and ted
are one of the most iconic on-screen
duos
they're sweet they're endearing and i
think so much of it is the chemistry
between the two of you the relationship
that you guys have had
on screen over the years i was wondering
if you could sort of tell me a little
bit about
sort of take me through the evolution
and how that relationship has changed
over the years both on screen and off
and
and was it instant when you guys met and
were the voices did they come easily or
just something you really worked on in
the audition process i think we hit it
off really quickly just as
as people and then um as aspiring
artists and through that having the
opportunity
uh to make the film and to act together
you know i think that just really
began you know deep into friendship and
the
camaraderie and also the art our craft
and then through the two films
uh and then being seen friends over the
30 years
yeah i agree i agree with keanu the you
know the the
we both you know have had our journeys
we've we've
uh we're very we have a very fraternal
relationship so we've been kind of
through a lot of stuff together over the
years as
one is in life when you have a close
friend and i think
going back to the first movie uh we
became friends in the audition process
we hit it off right away and there was a
physical
ease and familiarity with the way we we
both approach the characters
but also dylan's head was written uh by
chris mathis and ed solomon and they
were very close friends
and there's a a a very deep friendship
sort of woven into the movies
and we brought our friendship to that
so i think you know if the movie wasn't
about two really good friends
i think that you know it wouldn't have
had such an infectious quality but i
think the
the guys uh chris net have always
written really good repartee
so the dialogue is really great and and
it's very infectious to say that
dialogue and
the roles are very physical and even the
audition process was very physical
so um i think all of that is kind of
conspired to make them fun to play and i
guess fun for other people to watch
it's physical for us too because we
always mimic you watching them so i was
wondering in this film
was there something either or both
that was really important to you to hold
on to from the first one that you really
wanted to make sure you captured again
and or something new that you really was
important to you to bring to this one
yeah i mean i think you know alex and i
worked a lot with the
the writer's really cool about
collaborating with us
you know like they would and the
director dean paris so
um you know so with the material you
know they would
ask our feedback we would provide some
feedback so
alex and i really worked on the text um
and then with the characters just to
find out you know who are they 30 years
later and then through the story
i don't know what would you say alex
like we were kind of watched we were
like
guardian we because we interpreted our
way and like
we spent our weekends rehearsing and and
playing with the text and making sure
that
you know that the emotional journey was
made sense and the logic of
of the story is quite complicated i mean
the guys are very bright who write these
movies so
there's a lot of complexity underneath
the seeming stupidity and silliness of
it and
but as actors who have to kind of drive
that story we put a lot of effort into
making sure it made sense to us makes
make sense to the audience and that
our emotional journey can can you know
work through all of it and and
that's just the stuff that happened
behind the scenes because once the
cameras start rolling it's really the
two of us kind of in that gymnasium just
letting go
uh and that's the fun of playing bill
and ted is it's like we're not
sitting there thinking our way through
each take where you know we do the work
before we get there and then
we just have fun and uh and that's
that's one of the things that makes
playing those characters so enjoyable i
wanted to ask you i i saw your comic-con
chat that you did
and i i heard you both say that one of
your most favorite things to do on set
was sort of to watch
kanye and alex and pick up their
mannerisms so i was wondering like what
was the quintessential
keanu mannerism you picked up and what's
the quintessential alex like what's the
thing that stands out the most
well i think we should specify we
weren't
we were following uh bill and ted not
alex and keanu because then yeah
i know for me for keanu my favorite
thing that he does
as ted is the hair
[Laughter]
he kind of has the same hair now but he
had the hair
in the first movie and he would just and
like the arm
shape yeah i really like too yeah
i feel like keanu played ted kind of
floppy and malleable and
and alex was a little like stiffer and
like
uh kind of like kind of robotic in a in
a strange way
and they're funny it's so true because
as you're both saying that i can see it
like you can see it as you're saying it
so um
billy and thea how are they similar to
bill and ted
and how are they different their
personalities the apple doesn't fall far
from the tree but
um billy and fear uh they're geniuses
they're musical wizards and bill and ted
bless him
but they are in their own right though
they really have the secret to life
figured out they're totally in the
moment
they don't judge themselves they don't
feel bad about themselves they embrace
every
every moment i aim to be like them um in
real life are you anything like alex and
canon
do you have any similarities same taste
in movies to do
franchises that we attach ourselves to
i know keanu has an art like an artist
book company
um and i have a art magazine so i know
that that's like
a parallel yeah you know other than the
hair flip
it's not much how do you both in this
time that we're in how do you both party
on now
i mean it's a solo party right yeah
i'm in australia um and um
covered isn't as rampant here so
we can party we can party a little
carefully
the new york was pretty bad a couple
months ago but
that we started to loosen up but we
still just kind of hang out in parks but
i
realized that um the kids parks in new
york
keep the fountains on all night and so
often i'll just like pretend that i'm
just like hanging out at the park and
i'm like does anyone want to go in the
fountain
like by the end of the night all my
friends are just soaked oh
i love that that's fun um if you could
both travel to any time in history where
would you try
when would you travel to i think
dinosaurs
yeah dinosaurs that's a good call you
might get squishy
yeah we might get a bit squashed or
eaten but
would you be cool or open to a spin-off
having your own like billy and thea
spinoff sure because i think you could
fully have your own movie after seeing
you guys together
let me read the script if you call my
agents um
we'll figure it out your people call my
people we'll talk about it
you are the unsung third member of the
bill and ted
gang can you sort of give me that moment
on set when you all got back together
when you said to yourself
oh yes this is just like 30 years ago
this is what this is why we do it this
is why
this is the i mean there's the money or
there's the fame or there's the
you know it was so sweet when
the three of us were actually back on
set
for the first time after 29 years or 30
years or whatever it was
and it was really lovely it was like the
room filled up with
this energy again it was sort of like
you have old friends and it doesn't
matter how long
you've been apart you get back together
and you know it's like you never
separated like no time has passed at all
and that's sort of what it
that's kind of what it felt like it was
like the band got back together
you know yeah i was really i was really
pleased because i wasn't a part of the
band when it
you know in the first round ted movie
but but it was very nice to be added to
the band
well like i said you are the third
member of wild stallions
wanted to ask you going back to the last
film if you had to beat
death in a board game what board game
are you choosing to be death in
oh if i had to play a board game with
death yes
it would have to be like uh
it has to be like monopoly or something
it couldn't
it could i hate board games but it
couldn't be like
scrabble or something you know okay
because neither one of us can spell
that's death's an even worse speller
than me
no it would have to be like monopoly or
or trivia you know like true yeah
trivial pursuits i could do
i could kill him trivial pursuit i feel
like i should get out my cards now and
start asking
you know something like that one of
those ones where they ask you you know
do you remember the
can you name all the members of the
monkeys you know
some stupid really stupid inane
questions my head is full of that crap i
wanted to ask you
borrowing a theme from the movie where
there are parallel universes and we have
parallel lives if you
william had a parallel life what do you
think you would be doing
whoa um i thought i would be a musician
when i was in high school i was in a i
was in a garage band and
the reason i left the band was because
we we did nothing but covers
and i wanted to write i wanted to i
wanted to write the songs i wanted to
create the music not just recreate the
music and
um but music has just been so
central to um
my life it makes me happy it makes
you know i can't go through a day
without
music being a part of it so i guess if i
let me have a sense if i had apparel you
parallel life
i'd be like a jazz musician or something
you know
so what would be the one song that would
save the world um
oh bohemian rhapsody oh yes
yeah i think that could probably save
the world it comes close to saving the
world
okay well first of all anthony your
characters i'm a huge fan of barry
all the characters that you craft
including this movie are so delicious
so nuanced so intricate and they're such
a delight to watch
i'm wondering when you were creating
this character and i don't want to give
too much away to the audience i know you
want somewhat of a surprise but there
are certain restraints
that you have and where how did you make
it fit into the bill and ted universe or
do you not even think about that do you
just go i'm
anything goes well i think there was
obviously
the hurdle of just getting over my
nervous excited energy just to be a part
of the whole franchise you know which i
was
just such a huge fan of since i was a
kid
uh so i had to get i had to get over
that first and foremost
um but it was honestly just like a
really um
a really wonderful process of kind of
getting
just free reign to build the character
from the ground up on
you know obviously that i was given this
kind of concept that
says killer robot whose job it is to
destroy bill and ted um which is uh
you know i was like i'll take it hey
listen you know i love going ted but
you know any any way i can get involved
i'm down with um
but from that point on it was uh it was
a really fun process of just kind of
exploring who this character was
and and also how this costume could kind
of lend itself to
you know to what i could create how many
minutes was it to get into costume and
that and how
restraining was it or did you find it
freeing well it
it took a while it took a while um i
think it would probably take like
two two and a half hours each day to uh
to get into the full costume um and you
know at first
at first it was hard at first it was it
took some getting used to
especially we're shooting new orleans in
the summertime
very hot uh so i was trying not to die
um but but then i actually began to kind
of
incorporate that discomfort that i was
feeling and kind of let it
just let it be there for the character
so yeah uh
so overall though i just had a blast if
there was
a parallel a bunch of an infinite number
of parallel universes out there
and you had an infinite number of lives
what do you hope you're doing
in another life oh wow that's a great
question um
let me see uh
another life i think that i would be
i don't know i i i would like to say
that i would be an artist in some
respect
but i don't know i think it'd be pretty
cool
to um to be just like a really brainy
scientist who is kind of helping
humanity
i think that we can all just like be
very very very grateful for everyone
who's just working their
butts off trying to trying to save as
many lives as possible
so yeah yeah if i could choose you know
i would try to you know try to band
together with with that band of heroes
if you could visit yourself at any age
either a younger age or an older age
what age would you go to
and what kind of conversation would you
have with yourself that's a really great
question
um you know i would probably go to
[Music]
i think when i you know
was getting teased and bullied for my
alopecia
um not to like make it sad story or
anything but like you know i was kind of
you know going through my alopecia and
and thinking that there was something
wrong with me and so i think i would go
back and just be like hey
it's gonna be all good you know remember
that movie you watched last weekend
yeah at the sleepover bill and ted just
wait just
just wait you know i think i'll probably
you know just exactly just like
do that you know and then uh and then
disappear in my phone booth that reminds
me of my last question for you if you
could have any object
become your own personal time machine
what object would you choose wow what
these are these are the great questions
these are the questions that i
really need that i really really
appreciate are they excellent are they
excellent
they are most excellent they're most
non-heinous
you know i gotta say i'm spending a lot
of time on my couch so
that would be a pretty comfortable way
to travel honestly
i mean just kind of like grab a little
blanket you know a couple pillows
and um you know journey across the uh
the strength of time
going back to your you're talking about
your school days your younger self
what famous person would you want to
help you with your schoolwork
i mean the typical answer is is einstein
but i feel like i can
probably do better than that i mean i
can do better than einstein what am i
talking about
um i want to know i think i might just
kind of
uh let's see
i don't know i think maybe
let's say joan of arc okay but only if
it's played by
uh jane wiedland because jane wiedland
did play joan of arc
and she was in the go-go so you know
that would be a pretty
pretty fantastic person too i don't know
if you'd help me with my homework so
much as just inspire a revolution
in the school and just you know get
everyone to walk out and save the world
and save the world exactly there you go
you're playing the princesses
you know 30 years later but different
different people actresses playing the
roles
can you just bring us up to speed on
where the princesses are at now
very princessy really still
on a normal basis they've been
getting to know this time period this
location
they've had to get jobs they've kind of
had to be the providers for their family
i mean they had
wild stallions and then you you slowly
learn what the fate of wild stallions
were and i think eventually
um we had to get jobs because we became
teachers
uh so now you're at this you find
both these families and the princesses
kind of at this crux of dealing with
like what a
real long relationship is and the
pressures of
their husbands saving and uniting the
world
and what's that what that's done to
their marriage and themselves just a
little thing it's just a little bit just
small
small small little things they are
saving the universe and we want to be
happy while they're doing it
i kind of believe that this movie could
save the universe like you know there's
always the song that saves the universe
in this
but i really feel like this is the movie
that if everybody could share
could save the universe um i wanted to
ask you both if you could zoom with any
historical figure
who would you zoom with i would go talk
to princess joann
and the year 1256 or whatever
just to see and if the two of if you're
the two princesses were to form a band
you know we have the wild stallions what
would your name
be what would your abandoning be is
aerosmith taken
wild italians that like the tame
tigresses
alliteration right given at the time
that we're in
how do you how do you both feel we can
be excellent to each other right now
i think that the um the rule of a a good
marriage could apply to all of us right
now since we're all just
it's like find just be a little extra
nice to the people that are in your
sphere every day it's like that little
thing of
of um you know bring the coffee instead
of just
copies over there it's just like it's
little i think little kindnesses
throughout our day are what makes me
feel good in these moments
that's nice and i think yeah just going
off of that patience like for me i'm
constantly doing
that thing where you're going 10 9 8 7
6 like counting though you are a toddler
and i don't know how to go beyond fat
number by the way
um now i think having patience for not
just people in your house but for people
everywhere there's a lot of
emotions and there's just so much going
on i think patience
patience first of all i don't wanna i
always like to
let people go into movies without
knowing too much so i don't you tell me
too much about your character but if you
could just tell me your character
using like three words just three words
to describe smart
uh very smart
adventurous and and uh
fun-loving i mean that sounds like a
perfect person right
the perfect human good stuff that's
that's kid cuddy in the in the bill and
ted universe yeah there you go
there you go so i wanted to ask you
obviously with bill and ted there's
always the element of time at travel so
if you could travel back in time you
could jump into their phone booth
and you could go back and collaborate
with any musician in history
who would you collaborate with well this
is interesting because i i kind of just
answered this question
uh no i got to be original i got to be
the first one to ask you this
but i can give you a different answer
because i because this is multiple
different
versions like for this hit for this one
i said um
i said i would go back and get tupac and
biggie before they met
and introduce them and make sure that
they're friends and that they never beef
wow you know and i was actually saying
that that's a that's a movie
you know so i was like i'm about to
write this and i'm about to pitch it
can i be the producer can i get a
producer a second producer yes yes
okay well hopefully you haven't been
asked
this question um if you were to go
forward into the future
what do you think music is going to
sound like in the future
wow
i mean this is a question that i asked
myself
2009 when i was working on my debut i
was like what's the sound gonna be like
in 10 years
i want to make that you know
um so i think like with with this new
stuff
um that i'm working on
it's the same thing like what's the
sound gonna be like in 10 years
in 2030 what are we going to be hearing
you know
i want to make that so like it's it's
it's all about like you know
trying to push and create new sounds and
explore
i think we'll start hearing it'll be
really hard to
decipher genres because i think
everybody is going to be on this
blending genres and creating their own
sounds
um i think people are starting to see
that
that's the way to go it's kind of like
trying to create your own sound and that
that's what will propel you forward
that's how you'll have
longevity in the business um
so yeah i i feel i feel more hopeful
about the music industry about where
we're going than i did in 2009 i didn't
know i
i was just hopeful and i just didn't
know where we would be
i didn't know where i would be because i
knew at that time
that my music was very different than
anything else that was out um
in the mainstream uh so
yeah i i really feel good about the
future of music i think we'll we'll be
you know on a similar wave to what we're
doing now but a little bit more advanced
you know there'll be new keyboards and
all sorts of new ways to record and
all that you just got me very excited
about the future music
i mean you're known for having a sound
that nobody's ever heard before so
that's really cool
um given the time we're in now i've
taken you to the past and into the
future but given in the time that we're
in right now
how do you think we can be excellent to
each other to borrow a phrase
from bill and ted about being excellent
how do you think we can be excellent to
each other right now
in the world we can be a lot less
selfish and start caring about each
other next to us and
and and caring about what's going on in
the world
you know i think sometimes we in life we
can get so focused on what's right in
front of us
i think uh
the most important thing to do for us
right now um
in the nation and in the world is to
unite
and be together you know um especially
for us with with this whole donald trump
fiasco
it's like you know whenever we're gonna
get past that unless we come together
and stand up to that
you know so i think uh
that's that's something that could
really you know
that to me could be helpful and and
could push the world in the right
direction
you know which one of your own songs do
you think
could save the world oh wow hmm
this is interesting i never thought
about this
um if i could say any one of my songs
could save the world
uh it'd probably be pursuit of happiness
i was gonna say that one actually yeah
yeah yeah that's a good one yeah
i'm gonna be performing that song until
i'm like
65 it'll be like bill and ted
going into the future right yeah exactly
exactly
exactly what other artists like if you
could collaborate with any other artists
right now it could be more than one
to write a new song to save the save the
world and save the future who would you
collaborate with right now
oh that's easy that's easy um we'd have
to put andre 3000 in there
we'd have to put pharrell we'd have to
get kanye um
i mean that's like my dream team right
there if i just have those three dudes
like we can make something special you
know
um for sure and i i know i know how they
all create
so like you know we could really make
something tasty
would you ever sample any of bill and
ted's wild stallions music
oh yeah i haven't seen the movie yet but
um
so i haven't heard any of the music and
or anything um
but like in the originals like they used
to do these gnarly guitar solos
and it's like yeah like these twin
guitar solos and [ __ ] and like there's
there's another band named ratatat
that does uh stuff like that it's like
two dudes just kind of riffing on their
guitars you know
so like uh i was hoping that like in
this in this
this new movie that they would get back
to that that would be like their style
their future thing and like i heard uh
the the weezer song that they did for
the soundtrack and there's like a little
wild science section of them just doing
their guitar solo and i was like yes
yes okay and then given that the time
again the time we're in now to use
another phrase
from bill and ted how do you because
bill and ted are always saying party on
how do you party on now
already on in the in the quarantine uh i
kind of just like uh
chill in the studio and uh i've got my
weed there
and i've got some tequila sometimes and
i'm kind of just chilling out
and uh sometimes we play games sometimes
we play call of duty
uh but yeah it's really
way chill way more chill than than the
full-on rager mode
of the years before you know yeah okay
one last question real quick
you know how bill and ted have the phone
booth they use that to travel
what would be your object that you used
to time travel what object would you
choose
oh man um it would probably be my tesla
yeah model x man uh i would love to time
travel in that thing i feel like i am
time traveling on that thing
first thing i wanted to ask you i know
this this was conceived 30 years ago the
two of you performed these characters as
a sketch comedy at the black box theater
i'm wondering like if you're if i'm
taking you back to the beginning
when you first saw keanu and alex play
these roles
how much of it felt like what you guys
had done and how much
felt like oh my gosh i didn't even think
of that and this is what they brought
it's actually 36 years ago i stand
corrected
1983. so it's even longer ago than that
um i think that they did kind of what we
had in mind
and then they just elevated it so
spectacularly because our bill and ted
were kind of
they were kind of losers and then alex
and keanu show up
and they're definitely not definitely
not that if i had said to you guys
36 years later or 36 years ago that 36
years later
bill and ted are going to be married
they're going to have children and
they're going to have a third movie
what would the two of you the
performance have thought of that
we i remembered chris do you remember
this moment
uh i think it was at lake tahoe when we
were outlining the very
very first draft saying can you imagine
if we're 30 years old and still
writing bill and ted we were so wrong
because letting them now turned out to
be an incredibly meaningful experience i
i for myself think i mean i don't speak
for chris but i i think
you know i'm going to guess it fair it's
fair to say it was for you too
going back to the inner lives of these
characters that we
created when we were essentially
adolescents uh
is remarkable and if you had told me
back then when we didn't even know if
anyone would read the script
that 36 years later we
we'd be talking about bill and ted with
their grown-up daughters and another
movie
i would have just laughed is there are
there elements is there anything from
the first
two that either ended up on the cutting
room floor that you had ideas for that
you were like
yes we get to bring it into this third
one i don't think so
you know there's a lot we learned from
the first two stuff we learned that was
positive and stuff we learned that
was negative that we wanted to try to
either avoid or
um or do differently this time but
we never uh
like wish we could put something back in
that ended up on the cutting room floor
most stuff ended up on the cutting room
floor for for good reason
there are things from earlier scripts
that
in hindsight i wish we had kept that got
cut and sometimes we cut them because
we wanted to please people or we got
notes from a studio and we just had to
had to make changes sometimes just bad
judgment on our part
most of the time bad judgment on our
heart i don't think there's bad judgment
when there's when the fans
want a movie this many years later and
have demanded it over and over and over
and waited for it i don't think there's
really been any bad judgment on your
part first of all becoming part of this
franchise
um so beloved was it an instant yes for
you
or did you have to think about it oh
it's an instant yes i mean
i love those characters um and i also
love
what they sort of represent um and
not to mention those two actors who i
are just uh
i i have a huge affection for i've known
ed solomon uh
and chris matheson a little bit also but
ed moore for about
well since the early 90s so uh and we've
worked together on projects
um and um so it was it was easy
um the harder part was uh being attached
to it for seven years
it was 11 for ed and trying to get it
going because it's narrowing what
the genres are the genres are narrowing
but sort of what you're you sort of said
about
what they represent what does that mean
to you what do bill and ted represent
and is that sort of why they've endured
what you know for 30 years and why
people still want
a sequel after 30 years well yeah i mean
i think be excellent to each other um
is they are undeniably best friends
forever
nothing will get in the way of those two
and it would be a mistake to do that i
think and yet most dramas would do that
it's what's amazing about them the other
thing that's great about them is their
sort of delusional optimism and and
their their recovery time from tragedy
is very short
where they come up with a great idea
that we always think is crazy but
actually
ends up being correct they're
delusionally optimistic and they're
correct
and that's i love that and i think the
thing i i like most about this version
is the last sentence of the movie
actually
which is it's not the song so much it's
playing it together that
matters it occurred to me watching it
that they feel
like there's a fluidity between them
that you almost feel like it's one
entity not even two separate people
they're so in sync with each other
i call i used to call them a
single-celled organism because they're
but it's them it's like them in real
life too
i mean they've been best friends forever
and it's
uh they work really hard at it i mean
they're
they're both incredibly talented
filmmakers as well as
um gifted gifted actors and so
um you know that's them working off one
another all the time and yeah
seeing and really thinking about those
characters i mean
really in the end all i had to do was
watch um
an occasional a little conducting but it
just
it was great fun actually great fun well
you had a front row seat obviously um
you know when you talk about there's so
many people that would love to have that
front row seat and sort of watch
when was sort of the first moment was it
in a meeting was it a rehearsal because
i know they told me as well how much
rehearsal goes into
being free in the moment on set was
there a moment for you that you were
like
oh my gosh that's them that's the bill
and ted that everybody loves
what was that first moment for you it
was actually in a in a meeting
um the first meeting we had with a a
studio
um who shall remain nameless um
and we're in this big meeting and um you
know i've
met keanu and alex and i know ed for
years and we're all
we're all all talking about bill and ted
but i had not yet heard the two of them
go into it and all of a sudden
um they they played those voices and
everybody in the room just went well how
uh
it was it was kind of it's kind of
shocking and hysterical at the same time
so um uh and you know ed
and chris in college came up with those
voices that's how they yeah
they talk to each other in those voices
so um
but keanu and alex have definitely took
it one step
farther
on top of that they've sort of invented
a slang you know that became part of our
uh our pop culture really how did you
find the balance between playing the
hits and making sure you hit those notes
from 30 years ago that people love
and bringing something fresh to the
franchise well hopefully i did
um the challenge of this was to
contemporize it the key is to hold on to
who they are as people to hold on to the
essence
the character the friendship the never
give up attitude of those two
but then they've also they're also
middle-aged so you're i'm adapting to
this moment in time
there are very few movies i can think of
that
had a franchise that was 29 years old
and then started another one
so uh it was it was you had to bring it
you had to contemporarize it and make it
at this time so
maybe it's a little more grounded a
little more absurd
the film language hopefully is a little
more sophisticated of
this moment in time
you